all right you internet creatures i'm
dave rubin and today we have another
friday panel extravaganza for you
joining me today are three first-time
guests to the show editor-in-chief from
the post-millennial libby evans author
of the upcoming book am i crazy an
unapologetic patriot takes on the
insanity of today's woke world chad
prather who's also running for governor
of texas we'll get into that and opinion
journalist at the new york post the
often banned from twitter new york post
rav aurora welcome to the reuben report
everybody
thanks
great to be here
all right i'm glad to have the three of
you here i've wanted to have all of you
on for for quite some time uh there's a
lot to unpack today we're just gonna
review some of the nonsense of the week
but let's start with biden because he
gave a speech yesterday that was just an
endless
series of lies almost everything he said
was either an outright lie either
intentionally or
uh perhaps not intentionally if he
doesn't know what he's saying it's a
little unclear at this point so let's uh
let's throw to some video here's biden
on how unvaccinated people or sorry how
vaccinated people can't spread covid
and we know there is no other way to
beat the pandemic
than to get the vast majority of
americans vaccinated it's as simple as
that
and just
to spread to our children to spread
throughout society in our hospitals or
the risk of other variants it's all
dangerous and obvious but we're still
not there
we have to beat this thing
so while i didn't race uh
to do it right away
that's why i've had to move toward
requirements that everyone get
vaccinated or i had the authority to do
that that wasn't my first instinct
my administration is now requiring
federal workers to be vaccinated
we've also required federal contractors
to be vaccinated if you have a contract
with the federal government working for
the federal government you have to be
vaccinated
we're requiring active duty military to
be vaccinated we're making sure health
care workers are vaccinated because if
you seek care
at a healthcare facility you should have
the certainty that the people providing
that care are protected from covenant
and cannot spread it to you
okay so the last line there is is the
key line the implication being that if
you are vaccinated you cannot spread
covid libby uh before i spread it uh
before i spread it to you before i throw
it to you from nbc this week when
infected with the delta variant a given
contact was 65 percent less likely to
test positive if the person from whom
the exposure occurred was fully
vaccinated with two doses of the pfizer
vaccine so yes it sounds like it might
do something to stop the spread if
you're vaccinated but he's absolutely
lying there he's saying if you're
vaccinated you're not gonna spread
you've been writing a bit about this
i have been writing about this and that
speech was interesting for a number of
reasons one of which was that much of it
was entirely nonsensical the lies as you
point out as well but prior to his
giving a speech there were three people
that gave a speech beforehand uh spoke
laurie lightfoot among them and they
were all wearing masks they were wearing
masks at the microphone and undoubtedly
they are all vaccinated so if vaccinated
can't spread coven why is everybody all
mashed up
you know this is
i think we keep asking this question and
as to what biden was saying in terms of
his original instinct was not to require
any sort of mandates for vaccines which
of course he said
i believe um
in december something along those lines
he was very clear about that now he's
decided that
the crisis is so big and of course this
is a crisis president if there wasn't a
crisis he wouldn't know how to comport
himself but now the crisis is so big
that he has to
force americans to do things he has to
give up the principles that we all abide
by as americans who live under the
constitution and what he's forgetting is
that our rights are not his to give away
he doesn't have this power these are our
rights it's up to us we get to decide
what happens to us medically or at least
that's what the democrats have been
telling us for my entire life um so yeah
i think it's absolutely insane the way
that he's behaving and these nonsensical
speeches they keep trotting him out
every day to just unleash this
torrent of nothingness upon everybody
it's madness right so two other quick
points on that when he said the only way
we get out of this is basically to get
everyone vaccinated he's saying 98 i
mean that makes no sense if we're to
believe that two weeks to flatten the
curve that was the original thing
remember that a year and a half ago so
were they all crying about that and then
he also said because of the spread he
said because of the spread to children
and as i have repeated about a thousand
times this week cdc numbers not dave
rubin numbers uh
.002 percent of children die of covid
okay not too it is literally less than
hundred since the beginning of the
pandemic right not to diminish those
kids lives but not at all here we are uh
chad you are in the free state at least
the free state for now of texas how you
feeling about this whole situation and
that speech in particular
so first of all he's not lying he just
doesn't know what he's saying he has no
clue you're being generous yeah
he's a puppet right somebody's got their
hand up his ass and they're moving his
mouth uh joe biden after the afghanistan
debacle ought to be in prison or at
least in the basement of the old folks
home licking the window i mean the guy
is so out of brain that somebody has to
help him chew in order to eat pudding
but it doesn't matter
was telling the truth let's say he was
telling the truth dave and and the
vaccines work and everybody he wants
everybody to get the vaccine you know
the beautiful thing about the u.s
constitution is that it wasn't written
to keep you safe and it wasn't written
to keep you healthy because
written to keep you free
so regardless of whether or not the
vaccine is working or not to mandate
this in such a way is unconstitutional
it's a it's a violation of people's
liberties it's a violation of people's
rights if if you if you
worked for me let's say you're a female
and you worked for me and i came to you
as a male and i said hey you got to do
something for me if you want to keep
your job
you would sue me under the
i mean you would go you would go crazy
this is the exact same thing you're
asking
your employees to insert something in
their body in order to keep their jobs
the essence of this mandate
and this is what he's passing down this
is what he's talking about but it's not
a lie it's just more of the pablum that
he's spitting out and he doesn't even
remember what he said in days past in
regards to
right so in essence in essence uh he's
either just a blatant liar or he has no
idea what he's talking about it you know
and he's just reading whatever they put
in front of them it's hard to say which
one of those is true but you're making a
great point
about the vaccines related to mandates
in terms of work i have i have my
director in here and my producer in this
room with me right right now how insane
would it be if i was to say to them guys
the only way you can continue to work
for me is if you get injected with this
like what right i thought we're not into
slavery anymore what right would i have
to have them do that rob are we just
crazy freedom-loving people you're up in
canada are us americans are we just too
focused on freedom you're in canada
what's going on over there yeah no it's
very very similar um i would say it's
probably worse here with the
restrictions uh trudeau just announced
the uh restrictions on air travel you
have to be vaccinated by
november 30th um you still have a window
up until the 30th of november to
uh you opt for a negative cova test and
be able to travel after that you have to
be vaccinated which is a constitutional
violation in terms of freedom uh for
movement to be able to move around and
go places um but in that vitamin speech
i think there's something really
important to uh point out here which is
um what he said about the vaccinated not
being able to spread covet like the idea
that we should be uh we have to beat the
pandemic by getting everybody vaccinated
therefore
uh the spread will uh be reduced or
uh people won't spread at all okay that
is absolute scientific fiction
uh we know that um the vaccines are
incredibly effective at preventing
serious illness or death and that seems
to remain
um persistent after a number of months
it seems to offer a long-lasting
protection against a severe infection or
death however after several months
according to a recent uh study in qatar
that
dr j batacharya at stanford recently
appointed me to um it showed that after
about seven or eight months the
infection rate among the vaccinated is
roughly equal to that of the
unvaccinated and offers very little if
negligible uh protection against
infection and so we have real world data
also
supporting this point we see israel
highly highly vaccinated they're seeing
devastating third and fourth waves and
that's why pfizer and moderna they're
pushing for
the booster shot because they know the
protection against infection is very
very short the promise of the vaccine
has been exaggerated um and so you know
this idea is just completely false of
the vaccinated uh of just
not being able to infect others after a
few months and by the way to your point
about planes what they're doing in
canada trudeau saying you can't get on a
plane after november 30th
you know in effect if you're not
vaccinated every time that you get on a
plane all they do now is tell you how
safe planes are they show you videos of
masked people spraying things with green
guns and they tell you about the air
filters and that it's the safest place
possibly to be so are they lying or is
biden lying or trudeau lying it's a
little unclear we got one more from
biden because now it's not just that the
unvaccinated are going to get you sick
and they're most likely racist they're
also tanking the economy
we're headed in the right direction if
we don't we keep our eye on the ball
here we still have a long way to go
the fact is this has been a pandemic of
the unvaccinated
unvaccinated the unvaccinated overcrowd
are hospitals
overrunning emergency rooms and
intensive care units the unvaccinated
patients are
are leaving no room for someone with a
heart attack or in need of a cancer
operation and so much more because they
can't get into the icu they can't get
into the operating rooms
the unvaccinated also put our economy at
risk
because people are reluctant to go out
and think about this
even in places where there is no
restriction on going to restaurants and
gyms and movie theaters people are not
going
and anywhere near the numbers because
they're worried they're going to get
sick
oh the lies uh chad i'm going to throw
this one to you to start first off uh
overcrowded hospitals people dying on
the streets you know just gurneys
everywhere haven't seen any video or
pictures of that are you guys seeing
that in
texas and for some reason they just
can't get that out on the internet
no but i'll tell you what i am seeing i
was riding down the street in texas the
other day and i saw a billboard that had
a picture of medical professionals on it
and it said not all heroes wear masks
well apparently not all heroes get to
keep their jobs unless they get back
uh in the state of texas or why would
you fire medical professionals uh if
this were the case this was the
situation why would we be giving
termination letters and ultimatums to
the people who were in the trenches for
18 months dealing with this crisis and
to his point about people not going to
public places tomorrow is saturday which
college football season and every
stadium in america will be jam-packed
scrap
shouting let's go brandon and it's going
to be
people getting together just super
spreader events
yeah the beauty of us all coming
together to chant let's go brandon that
is see they say we have no national
cohesion but maybe not uh libya to that
point this people are reluctant to go
out thing
if to the degree that that's true could
that be because everything they say is
so conflicting and confusing and they're
making everybody afraid and scared
yeah i also think it's entirely untrue i
live in new york city and when i walk
out into the streets in brooklyn they
are packed just like they used to be uh
downtown manhattan is full it's been
full for months and months and months
and months so there's people everywhere
none of these people seem afraid they're
you know in brooklyn there's a lot of
people wearing masks there's a lot of
people about wearing masks when they
walk around but as soon as they sit down
at a cafe and get wasted they take their
masks off and then they wander around
and puke on each other just like they
used to and i think
you know the unvaccinated are just the
new grandma killers biden always has
someone to blame and this is just the
latest iteration and like you said these
people are likely racist
trump-supporting
redneck grandma-killing anti-vaxxer
conspiracy theorists and as soon as we
get rid of them maybe they're also
speaking at school board meetings then
of course the nation will be
far better off and as for the confusion
i think confusion is much of the point
so long as nobody has any idea what the
[ __ ] they're talking about and what
they're saying and what they mean we'll
just all throw up our hands and say all
right fine we don't know what's going on
why don't you just tell us what to do uh
and i think that's much of the goal that
is a well
f-bomb
yeah and we'll see it with climate
change too that's the next
you